قد اشار هو الزبيل الياس كرام عن سقوط
صواريقه بالتالي نتائج هذه الصواريخ
الاسعاف الاسرائيلي يقول نقلنا ثلاثه
مصابين بجروح صعبه ومتوسطه في بلده شوكيده
اثراء سقوط قذيفه صاروخيه
اذا متابعه لهذا الخبر العاجل معنا من
جنوب عسقلان مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الياس
بالفعل عبد القادر هذا هذه الانباء التي
يريدها الاسعاف الاسرائيلي قبل قليل عن
اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص في بلده شوكيدا الواقعه
في المجلس الاقليمي ازداد ناجح وهذا
المجلس الاقليمي يضم عده بلدات اسرائيليه
في منطقه غلاف في غزه يبدو ان قذيفه
صاروخيه سقطت في منطقه مفتوحه هذه المره
في بلده شوكيدا وادت الى اصابه ثلاثه
اشخاص احدى هذه الاصابات توصف بانها خطيره
والاصابتين الاخريتين هي اصابات متوسطه
الاسعاف الاسرائيلي بالتعاون مع قوات
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعملان على اجلاء
المصابين من الموقع الى ربما مستشفى
سوروكا في بئر السبع وهي ربما الاقرب الان
لتلقي العلاج وهذا يؤكد ما كنا نقوله في
الايام السابقه على ان سقوط القذائف
الصاروخ ايضا في مناطق مفتوحه لا تغطيها
القبه الحديديه من شانه ان يؤدي الى وقوع
اصابات في صفوف الاسرائيليين وايضا اصابات
مباشره في بعض المباني الزراعيه والمنشات
الصناعيه في تلك المناطق الحديث الاولي هو
عن ان الثلاثه هم ربما من رعاه الاغنام
الذين كانوا في تلك المنطقه نحن ننتظر
ربما مزيد من التفاصيل حول ذلك لكن
الاصابه كما يبدو جاءت مباشره او قريبه من
هؤلاء الاشخاص الثلاثه والاصابه على الاقل
اصابه واحد منهم هي اصابه اصابه البلدات
الاسرائيليه المتاخمه والملاصقه
للسياج الامني عبد القادر تعرضت في
الساعات الاخيره لدفعات صاروخيه متتاليه
ولقذائفه قصيره المدى والقذائف قصيره
المدى القبه الحديديه لا يمكنها ان تتعامل
معها وبالتالي هي تسقط ولا يمكن للقبه
الحديديه ان تعترضها او ان تسقطها
وبالتالي الجيش الاسرائيلي كما تعلم يعمل
في الشهور وربما في العامين الماضيين على
تطوير منظومه جديده في محاوله
لاعتراض هذه المقذوفات قصيره المدى تحديدا
قذائف الهاون والتي تسمى بالعبريه كيرن
ليزر اي الشعاع الليزر وهذا هذه المنظومه
الجديده لم تدخل بعد حيز العمل في سلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي المسؤول عن تفعيل
المضادات الارضيه ذلك ان هذه المنظومه ما
زالت قيد الاختبار وهي مخصصه تحديدا لمثل
هذه القذائف
الصاروخيه قصيره المدى وتحديدا قذائف
الهاون التي يبدو ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تطلقها
القذائف الصاروخيه قصيره المدى قذائف
الهاون التي كانت اوقعت في السابق عبد
القادر قتلى وجرحى في صفوف الاسرائيليين
في
معارك سابقه وفي جولات قتال سابقه